clean eating this is one of the biggest
movements like clean eating is just
going to be outrageous attention is the
number one
asset Arana is so that is like
the mecca of Los Angeles now it is I
know people that literally go to LA to
do business just so they can go to aan
like literally actually and think the
smoothie that is like $49 they sell $49
dollar smoothies and people are
lined up clean eating and they have
Balenciaga collaborations clean
this is one of the biggest movements
like clean eating is just going to be
outrageous like all the biggest brands
in the world in 20 years people are
going to be like what are these Brands
they're all building right now it's
about ingredients not calories and it's
going to be a big deal same with skare